here
Well, happy Sunday to you church. It's great to be back with you had a
great week off last week, but it's also great to know that God's word will still
be proclaimed. Even when I'm not here. I didn't Craig do
a great job last week with Psalms. I mean, it just was a
powerful powerful story and I pray in fact affected your
life as it did mine watching it later. But
here's the the thought today as
we go into today and over the next couple weeks. It's going
to be a little bit different than what we normally do walking through books
to the Bible. But as you just saw we're starting a short series around Easter
called that you may believe
and that phrase is taken from John 20 30 and
31 where the Apostle John said that out of the the millions
of options. He could have picked to write
down he chose what he chose to write
because he wanted you to believe that
Jesus is the Christ the son of God and that
by believing you would have life in his name.
So that was his purpose in writing and so we know that's why John was written
but if you think about it.
there's first four books of the New Testament of Matthew Mark Luke
and John like I just mentioned if you think about it, that's
What we can safely assume that that's why all four
of those would have written right? So in Matthew
and Mark and Luke would have written also.
So that people would believe that Jesus
is the son of God.
Because when you think about it, they were not writing biographies about
Jesus.
Because they exclude so much of his life. It's a
terrible biography right you skip so many years. It's
just there's there's certain parts that they selected. They
were not writing biographies. They were writing gospel
accounts.
That's why if you look at the title of each in your Bible and when
you look at it, it actually says The Gospel according to
Matthew or to Mark
or Luke or John. That's the actual title. Not just the
name.
By the way, remember that the word gospel in the original language actually just means
good news. So they would tell gospels of
Victories and other things the gospel is good
news. Well good news about what here if we're
talking about. This gospel. Good news about Jesus, right?
Specifically as First Corinthians 15 says specifically
jesus' life death and Resurrection. That's the
gospel good news that we are talking about here. That's
why each of these four gospel writers focused primarily
on the last three years of jesus' Earthly
life.
That's the time frame that mostly encompasses his
public life his death his resurrection.
That was their main priority. Why because again,
they wanted their readers.
And you and I to believe.
This is what they wanted people to believe and so over the next
three weeks. We're going to look at The Gospel according to
Matthew the Gospel According to Mark and
The Gospel according to John.
Now, why do we skip Luke? Well, because we did Luke last year the whole
Easter was around Luke. And so we saw that now
we're going to Matthew Mark and John this year and we're going to see
how each one of those uniquely shows their
perspective on this good news
about Jesus.
Why did Matthew and Mark and John say it
the way they said it as they looked at the good news of Jesus
and what we're praying for is for belief as a result
of that.
That you may believe.
That's the goal.
So just as a heads up, like I said, it's going to be a little bit different. We're
going to bounce around some.
We're gonna get a little technical at times.
And so it's going to at times feel a little apologetically.
I don't if that's even a word but sounds right.
So we're gonna it's gonna sound some of that like defending
the face in some ways.
Which means kids students?
It's going to feel a little bit like an upper level course in some
ways. We're going to talk some technical things. And so I know
you guys can handle that. And so you're going to follow along right with me, right?
This is how it's going to be.
Because for many of us adults included
you will be challenged and helped
by this in your faith.
Because there's going to be things you're going to learn about who God
is new things that you've never thought through before he
worked how he worked how he let us read
about it in his word.
Listen, I even know that some of you are are skeptical.
You're doubting this whole thing about Christianity in general faith.
Which Jesus really who he said was even real and you're
wavering.
Maybe you have faith but you don't really have
certainty about some things My Hope Is that in
all of this? You would see the kind of firm foundation
you can have in Jesus.
This would lead you towards that.
And finally, I don't know there's some of you who think man. I already know all that.
even if you know everything that I'm about to say
Let this series reawaken you.
to the The Wonder of the Gospel
to the beauty and infinite depths of
the grace of God for us.
Let this stir your affection for Jesus even more this Easter
season.
It's got help us towards that.
Help us towards those ends whether we're Believers or
not.
mature immature wherever we land on
this God show us who you are lead
us to see you and believe
in the sense of you wanting us
to believe
help us God.
In Jesus name we pray. Amen. Amen.
Okay. So today we're going to be in The Gospel according to Matthew. And
so take your copy of God's word and turn there with
me Matthew chapter 27 is where we're going to end up Landing very
end of Matthew the very end of chapter 27, Matthew
27.
Before we get there though.
Some work we need to do to set a foundation. We
need to First understand the nature of these
gospels of the Gospel accounts.
We understand the nature of the gospels and we
need to understand the makeup of these first four books
of the New Testament that tell us the good news of Jesus.
So as I said that they do contain biographical information
like who is parents and where he lived those kind
of things, but they're not biographies about Jesus.
What these are is these are eyewitness testimony?
Each of these four are eyewitness testimony.
This is the nature of the gospels. They were collecting
each four. Each of the four were collecting first-hand accounts of Jesus's
life.
Now I want to be clear as we jump into this.
In all of this. I'm assuming the Holy Spirit has inspired
it all along the way.
Right. This is not just four guys writing down things for posterity. Right
this this is the holy spirit inspiring these words. That's
why we can call this God's word with confidence.
So I might not say that all the time but no that's behind the scenes
of this. Okay?
Critical but but how he did that is interesting how he
did that is by using either the person writing or
a direct source who was there?
So think about it Matthew also called Levi
in some parts. He he was one of
the Twelve Apostles. He was a tax collector before he followed Jesus and
so Matthew was there he saw it
heard it. He felt it.
That's Matthew. Then you have Mark who's all known as John Mark
later in the Bible. He probably got everything.
He wrote from Peter.
Close compatriot with Peter.
Although next week. I'm going to argue that Mark was actually there too. I think
but anyway, we'll get to that next week.
Luke was a doctor who traveled with Paul and did
extensive research into all of this talking to eyewitness accounts
recording it all.
And then you have John one of The Twelve Apostles is
where as well. Even even in the Inner Circle
of three that Jesus had John was one of those and so
he would have seen it and heard it all.
But again, they were not just writing for the future just to record events.
They wanted people to believe right?
That's what John said. I already read that earlier. This is what Luke wrote
his for. This is Luke chapter 1 verses
1 through 4 in as much as many of undertaken to compile
and Narrative of the things that have been accomplished Among Us
just as those who were from the beginning where I Witnesses
and Ministers of the word have delivered them to
us, right? So he's saying I talked to people who are there.
It seemed good to me. Also having followed all things
closely for some time past to write an orderly
account for you. Most excellent Theophilus. Now here
it is that you may have certainty concerning
the things you've been taught.
So that you may believe right? That's what Luke says
even he wrote for so when you read the gospels,
they don't read like a biography.
And that's on point that's on purpose. They
read like an eyewitness getting up and sharing their
testimony in a courtroom. Yeah, you've seen
this before maybe maybe you've seen it in a movie or TV show and you
see what happens when the testimony is given by an eyewitness, right?
Here's what I saw. Here's what I heard. Here's who
was there here's how they reacted. Here's what I felt right?
That's I witness testimony. That's what's going
on here in the Gospels.
eyewitness testimony
So it doesn't always follow perfect order. So it doesn't always follow
chronologically, right? There's testimony. They're giving
to who he is.
Along with that. Here's the second characteristic of the gospels. It's
that they were independently written.
I believe they were independently written.
Now many people believe today that Mark was written first.
And then Matthew and Luke were based on it along
with another source called
q that we don't have any record of or any account
of any more.
The problem with that is that the Bible never says
that's how it went down.
And early Christians you go
back and read early writings. They nearly all agreed
that Matthew was written first.
And that they didn't use Matthew. They just wrote them
independently.
The probably now now think about this they were all in
their same circles. So they probably would have exchanged some information along the
way and say hey when we were at that place that what
did he say that and they would have to recall what it was.
But each of them also had sources of information that the others didn't
have.
So you have these these inward accounts from John you
have these others friends that they met that Luke research
that that Mark didn't talk to you. See there's Independence there
now are all the gospels similar.
Yeah.
Especially Matthew Mark and Luke are are very
similar in the way. They write things. Why is that?
Because the holy spirit's inspiring this thing, right?
He's superintending how all of this works, but also think
about how the early church worked.
They were constantly repeating all of this information to each
other that were recounting jesus' work
his words. They were talking with this one another
in early Church Life.
That's why Acts 2 remember Acts 2:42. They
devoted themselves to the apostles' teaching.
What were the apostles teaching?
Jesus
Jesus did said acted like
thought like this they were teaching.
What Jesus had done?
And so think they were devoted to it repeated it over and
over and over and over it became very similar.
So why are there differences?
Were they not just memorizing a bunch of facts about Jesus? Why are
there differences between the four Gospels?
Well first because they're uniquely written right Matthew wrote Mark wrote.
Luke wrote John wrote. We're going to highlight some of those differences along
the way in the next couple weeks.
but let me give you an example think of how
differently a husband and a wife would
describe what they did yesterday.
husband
What'd you do?
Well, we worked in the yard. We went to the hardware store and we
had lunch.
The wife would say we planted
flowers. We talked to our friends at
the store that we saw and we hadn't seen them a long
time. And then we we had an argument
at lunch because he ordered a milkshake even though he's lactose intolerant and
we had like all of that.
Now are there discrepancies there?
No.
Those things happened.
They just look at it from a different angle, right?
She saw running into the
friends at the store as a much bigger deal than going to the hardware
store in first place.
And so she kind of omitted that fact but it happened. She
just didn't say anything about it because she was focused on the friends.
And he completely forgot that they had the argument because the lunch was a
highlight of his day.
Right. So you see how this all works together. That's
the nature of eyewitness testimony it all
is the same events. It's just from a different angle that
they're looking at it.
It's the nature of it you get the same Basics, but you get a different focus. And
so that that leads to the third characteristic of
the Gospels.
Is that they were each uniquely focused.
There's four of them and each of the four had a unique
Focus. They told the good news of Jesus from
an angle.
and we shouldn't be too strict on these categories, but generally
Generally, you can say that Matthew is the gospel of
the Messiah.
The Christ the promised one and he's
focused on people with a Jewish background.
We'll get into that a little bit later mark.
Is the gospel of the suffering Son of God?
Mark moves really fast through things, but it's also the
most simple and direct to understand.
Then you have Luke.
as the gospel of the Savior for all people
even the Gentiles like you and me. He said
Jesus came for them too, because that's what Luke was.
And he highlights major themes of
Jesus's life and Ministry throughout his gospel.
And you have John is the gospel of
the Divine son who reveals the
father.
The most theological of all the gospels, but also
the most different he wrote really late compared to
the other three it seems and so it's very different.
But you can see why he wrote that way. Each each
was inspired Again by the Holy Spirit to write
in a certain way, but they were looking at it this life death
and resurrection of Jesus. They were looking at it through certain lenses.
They were looking at it through priorities that
they had as they were writing these accounts of Jesus.
They each wanted to accentuate a specific and unique
portrait of Jesus.
Yet yet. They're amazingly cohesive.
Even as they're looking at it from these angles. It's cohesive again
as a result of the holy spirit superintending all
of it.
But think about their diversity then.
They're cohesive and they fit together, but they're diversity
only gives us a deeper richer
Glimpse at this mystery of
Christ.
You can see things when you start to walk together that just
just deepen your faith in that.
There's no contradictions here.
There's things we have to kind of think through of course, but there's no contradictions.
And so when you look at differences between the Gospels, don't
let those lead you away from Christ.
Don't let that lead you away from Christ. Let the different
facets you see in Matthew and Mark and Luke and
John let that lead you to Christ. Let those lead
you to worship him when you see the depth
and richness of our God.
But as I talk through all those differences and all those similarities and things like
that at the core of everything in all four Gospels.
Is the basic Narrative of the Gospel
message?
The Narrative of good news about Jesus's life
death and Resurrection
Right. That's the thread through all of
it.
Now the gospels each of them includes more than that, right? You've
got Parables You've Got Back stories and
all those things. Yeah, you've got a lot of other things in there, but the
basic thread that I'm about to share
with you gonna walk through it quickly is in
all four of them.
And it's nearly exactly you can pull all of
this out from nearly all four exactly.
And listen, this is something that you and I need to need to
be remembering.
Not only at this season of Easter.
but all year
we talked a lot about here being a gospel-centered people
gospel-centered church. It's because this is the
power of God for salvation for those who believe.
The gospel is not not just the Bible not just
church. It is the gospel.
And so what do we need to remember?
This Easter season as we go the rest
of our lives. What is the thread running through all four
gospels that that is the good news of
Jesus life death and Resurrection.
Well, what is it? It's that Jesus.
Was eternal and yet took on flesh and
was born of a virgin 2000 years ago.
He lived a perfect life in submission to
his Earthly parents for 30 years.
He performed then publicly Miracles and he
taught old truths in a new and refined kind of
way.
and he was marked by the religious leaders
as an insurrectionist and he he was
he was being searched as a way to destroy him.
Because he was gaining a following.
But he was in control the whole time.
Over nature over his own life over even his
opposers.
And after three years of ministry a week before
the Passover, he entered Jerusalem fully aware
of what awaited him on the other side of that wall.
And he walks into the temple and cleanses it as an illustration of
what he's coming to do spiritually.
And he defeated and debated the
religious leaders and predicted what was coming
for those who don't repent and don't turn to him as
the Messiah.
And as he entered that night he observed the
Passover meal with his disciples and in
that he washed their feet. He took his disciples then out
to the Garden to pray with them and he was betrayed there
by one of his friends.
He washed their feet, even the one who
was about to betray me. He knew it was coming
and yet he did it anyway.
And in that betrayal he was wrongfully arrested. He
was illegal illegally tried multiple times. He
was denied three times in that by one of his closest friends.
And he was tortured he was nailed to a cross and he
was mocked. He was spat upon in that and he
finally on that cross gave up his life to pay the penalty for
our sin.
And when he died the curtain of the temple split
into top to bottom reopening the
way back to God he was taken down from the
cross. He was buried in a new Tomb.
but
after three days
He walked out of that tomb alive
again.
And so what he did in that moment is he appeared
to many that hundreds of people who proved
that he was resurrected and then when he
spent some time with them he ascended back
to heaven where he now sits as the King of Kings over
all things.
And so in that last whatever many seconds that is
the thread that flows through the
Gospels.
Because it is the gospel.
Because it is the good news of Jesus
in our place of sinners like
you and me having a hope in him. And why
did he do all that?
He did all that because he loves.
Because he loves us and again, that's not
a truth that we should remember only at Easter. That's
a truth for every season.
It's a truth for every day. It's the basic gospel that
we must look for and we must celebrate when we see it
throughout the gospels when we understand it being taught by Paul
later. We see it being predicted in the Old Testament. That's the
gospel. We celebrate here.
And so that's the thread yet as I said before.
I said that there are nuances in each of
these four gospels that deepen our
understanding of who Jesus is and what he's done.
Right. There's a reason that these look at it from an angle and
we're going to look at Matthew specifically today his uniqueness.
Mark next week John on Easter Sunday
with all of that. What is it about
what they write that makes it unique that
we can understand and believe who Jesus actually is
So you remember that that Matthew?
Matthew was written mostly to a Jewish audience.
They would have had the what we know as the Old
Testament.
And they would have read that looking for the Messiah
and so they're reading it with those lenses on
and that's why Matthew focuses. So
heavily on how Jesus fulfilled the Old
Testament prophecies.
Because Matthew wanted his readers primarily Jewish people
to believe that Jesus was
foretold.
He was predicted. This is the one you've been waiting for the Messiah
here. He is and so all over Matthew.
There are references to the Old Testament.
Some are very clear some are kind of vague, but
there's at least 20 times.
In 28 chapters where Matthew explicitly ties
something that Jesus says or does
something about Jesus ties it to an Old Testament
Prophecy of the Messiah to come.
more than any other gospels Matthew does this
Because he's writing in that angle.
It's what Jesus himself did so Matthew don't think Matthew is like
coming up with something out of thin air here.
Jesus himself did this I'm going to quote something from Luke. But
but listen to what Jesus does Luke 24:27.
This is after he resurrected. He's walking on the road to
Emmaus talking to these buddies beginning with Moses
and all the prophets.
Now that would be what we know as the Old Testament Moses and
the prophets the first five books and the prophets That Old Testament
so long before Jesus showed up on the
scene physically right beginning with Moses and
the prophets Jesus interpreted to them in all the
scriptures the things concerning himself.
Right. So Jesus Took the Old Testament and
said here's where it says this about me.
Here's what it shows me. Here's what it shows me. Jesus himself
did what Matthew is doing?
because again
Matthew wanted to convince his readers to
believe.
Let's look at this. Do you not see it?
Jewish primarily Jewish readers like do you
see Jesus is the promised Messiah? He's
the one even waiting for.
believe
Give your life.
Well, that's what then brings us to Matthew chapter
27.
Some of your like finally that was the longest introduction in the history
of introductions.
You see now where I'm going with this.
We're going to start in Matthew 27 starting in verse 62 gonna
read into chapter 28 a little bit.
But but notice this is right after Jesus was
taken off the cross. He was buried.
in the Tomb Here's Where We
Are
Matthew 27 verse 62
So jesus' body still in the Tomb at this point the next
day that is after the day of preparation the chief priests
and the Pharisees gathered before Pilate. That's the Roman
leader in that area. He said sir. We
remember how that impostor said while
he was still alive after three days. I will rise.
therefore pilate order the tomb to be made secure until
the third day lest his disciples go
and steal him away and tell the people he's risen from
the dead and the last fraud will
be worse than the first
so pilate said to them. All right, you have a guard a number of soldiers
go make it as secure as you can.
So they went and made the tomb secure by sealing the stone and setting
a guard.
into 28 now after the Sabbath
so this would be Sunday morning toward the dawn of the first
day of the week Mary Magdalene the other Mary went to
see the tomb.
And behold there was a great earthquake.
For an age of the Lord descended from heaven and came and rolled
back the stone and sat on it.
His appearance was like lightning his clothing. Why does
snow and for fear of him? The guards trembled
and became like dead men.
But the angel said to the women do not be afraid.
For I know that you seek Jesus who was crucified.
He is not here for he has risen
as he said.
Come see the place where he lay.
Like get proof look he's not here and then go quickly
and tell his disciples that he has risen from the
dead and behold he's going before you to Galilee there. You will
see him. See I've told you.
And so the women departed quickly from the tomb and with
fear and great joy and ran to tell
his disciples and behold Jesus met them.
And said greetings and they
came up and took hold of his feet and worshiped him and Jesus
said to them just like the angel do not be afraid.
Go and tell my brothers to go to Galilee and there they'll see
me.
I look at verse 11, we don't often read this part while they were going behold.
Some of the Guard went into the City and told
the chief priests all that had taken place.
And when they had assembled with the elders and taken counsel, they
gave a sufficient sum of money to the soldiers and
said tell people his disciples came by
night and stole him away while we were asleep.
And if this comes to the governor's ears, we'll satisfy him
and keep you out of trouble.
So they took the money and did as they were directed and this story
has been spread among the Jews to this
day.
Now, why did I choose this passage of
scripture today?
Out of all the rest. Why did I pick this one?
because the majority of these verses
only occur in Matthew and not
any of the other gospel accounts.
Nobody else talks about the guards. Nobody else talks about
the angel. Nobody else talks about this this interaction behind
the scenes with the guards and the chief leaders.
Why would Matthew include those?
When no one else did why would Matthew pick these things
out of the millions of things? Why did Matthew pick this? What
was his purpose in writing remember?
to convince the Jews to believe
and so what was going on here?
Well Matthew was giving an account of how
the Jewish leaders were corrupt.
How the Jewish leaders were trying to cover this up how they
were trying to pay off the guards to lie for them so that
they didn't have to deal with the consequences of Jesus being alive
again.
But notice what else Matthew included?
He says it was an angel who rolled the stone away. Nobody else
says that the guard saw it passed out because
of it.
And then that same Angel was who declared the truth of
Christ's Resurrection to the Mary's.
Right, the the angel opened the
tomb and declared the resurrection, but not only
all that Matthew also uniquely includes that
the women were the first ones to proclaim the
resurrection to fellow humans.
It was an angel to them they ran and told the disciples.
And so here's why all this is so important.
In spite of all that against it.
Right, so you've got the religious Elite conspiring
against this thing?
You've got an angel being involved which everybody can discount
that right?
You've got women's testimonies who are not even admissible in
a court of law at that time.
In spite of all of that against it the
gospel was still going forth.
That right because Matthew's writing years later. He's
looking back at this and saying in spite of all of that against
it.
Even though there's still circulating this lie to
that day. He's writing. It's still going forth.
It's still going forth in power. See that's what Matthew
wanted his readers to understand.
Everything was stacked against this deck.
Like the the leader of the movement had even
been killed and he was behind that stone. So they
thought
but nothing could stop God's work of
Salvation in the world.
Everything everything looked like it was against this movement tiny
little group of people like just a handful, right?
12 maybe a couple dozen more
That was it not some revolutionary Army the
leaders dead. The whole religious system is
against this.
And it's still working.
Nothing can stop God's work
of Salvation in the world.
Right because the promised one Matthew says had come
to save and deliver his people.
No conspiracy. No money. No power no
death. No bias could stop.
This work of God's salvation.
In other words, we say it this way.
The power of the Resurrection is Unstoppable.
Like he really did come back to
life.
There's no power stronger than that.
And Matthew and these other disciples they gave their
lives for this good news because they
were convinced that Jesus was the promised Messiah and
risen Messiah.
They had seen and heard and believed that this
Jesus lived died and resurrected for
them.
I said this is it.
This is the good news. There is nothing else we were living
for now. This is it. So again, Matthew notice
Matthew was making a case for his fellow
Jews to believe that Jesus was the
Messiah that this is the good news message.
He's pleading with his fellow Jews say
This Is What You Must Believe
Well today.
I've used God's word.
To make a case for you.
I've shown you eyewitnesses.
I've connected dots together.
All to show you that this is true.
That this is trustworthy.
And that you and I ought to believe in this
Jesus.
And so do you believe?
Like do you believe this have have you turned from
your sin and yourself? That deserves the
cross?
Have you turned from yourself in that and
turned to Jesus in faith in his life death
and Resurrection this good news counting for
yours.
if you have
if you have believed that then then again let
this let this Easter season stir your affections for
Jesus.
And this gospel is good news.
I want to challenge you over the next couple weeks.
To deeply remember the gospel.
To to reflect on why
this is so important for our lives.
And so often we just kind of go through this this normal
Christian Life and we're kind of decent people. We just
go through things. We we get to the end and we sort of
look back at the week and we're like, oh, okay, I did, okay.
Don't just live a Christian like kind
of life.
reflect on the gospel and be transformed
be completely new.
Because there's listen.
Resurrection is the main part of the
story.
And so when you're dead and he makes you alive don't you think
that's gonna change something.
Let that change everything and think
where does God even need to bring some Resurrection in
your life right now?
Like this Easter season can be a a Resurrection season
for some things in you.
That you've thought is hopeless that you've thought is just dead and you
you can you can dig deep into the gospel
and watch God bring new life.
challenge you to that
to not just go through Easter again.
but to deeply reflect on who he is and what he's done as Matthew
has shown us as Mark and John will show us
But I know some of you haven't.
Repented and believed yet.
my prayer
Is that you've seen God's word?
That it can be Trust.
To show you who Jesus is.
this
is who Jesus is that he lived the perfect life
that you and I could never live on our own.
That he died a substitutionary death
on the cross for your sin.
and then
He defeated sin and death by coming
out of that grave alive.
So that you can have Resurrection too.
You are dead in your sin.
eternally
Unless he takes you out of that grave and makes you
alive too.
By faith in this good news
message.
by faith in Jesus
See, this is our God.
believe him
trust him.
follow him
because he is worth this is the king of kings.
He's worth it.
This is what he's done because he loves us it's worth it.